as possibly the worst port and supply
chain crisis in america's history roils
the economy and threatens to continue
all the way through christmas and beyond
it is just now being reported that
transportation secretary pete bootage
has been on paternity leave for the past
two months
and has no plans of coming back to work
anytime soon
everything and i really mean everything
about this story is wrong sad and
ridiculous broadcasting live from clown
world i'm michael knowles this is the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment friday is from open eye who says
let's not forget magic johnson literally
got to play basketball while hiv
positive yes that's true but basketball
players who have already had the wuflu
who have already recovered from the
wuhan cough they're not allowed to play
if they don't get the vaccine kyrie
irving for instance he doesn't get to
play unless he gets the vaccine but if
you have
one of the worst diseases in modern
history that's totally fine that's no
big deal because at least you don't have
the symptoms of a mild cold in most
cases
this crazy techno tyranny is enough to
make you want to lock down all your
information which is why i would
strongly recommend you check out
expressvpn big tech is more powerful
than most countries are and they profit
by exploiting your personal data
it is time to put a layer of protection
between your online activity and big
tech okay which is why i use expressvpn
when you use expressvpn on your device
the software hides your ip address
something big tech can use to personally
identify you so expressvpn makes your
activity harder to trace and sell to
advertisers it encrypts 100 of your
internet data to keep you safe from
hackers and eavesdroppers on your
network does all of this without slowing
your connection it's just so easy just
click a button boom you're done that's
why it's rated the number one vpn
service by cnet and techradar it's so
simple to use you just download it on
your phone or your computer or both like
me and you're protected stop handing
over your personal data to the big tech
monopoly that minds your activity and
sells your info protect yourself with
the vpni trust to keep me safe online
visit expressvpn.com michael that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
michael to get three extra months free
go to expressvpn.com michael right now
to learn more pete but a judge
secretary of transportation
is missing an action
because he is on paternity leave
i got in a lot of trouble over the
weekend on twitter because i made fun of
pete bootage's paternity leave and
i would say just about every
conservative is mocking
this incident the buddha judge paternity
leave but they're doing so with varying
degrees of breadth
meaning everyone is mocking the idea
that the transportation secretary just
disappeared a cabinet secretary
disappears for two months but there's
more
wrong to this story than just that all
right so i think there are three aspects
of this that are really really wrong the
first one we all agree on
no cabinet secretary should be able to
just disappear for two months for
paternity leave or any other reason and
if they do disappear for two months they
need to be replaced it's kind of funny
that
no one even noticed buddha judge was
gone frankly if he'd been around he'd
probably make things worse but no
cabinet secretary should be able to just
disappear for two months okay that's the
first thing that's wrong
the second aspect that's wrong with this
is more specific to buddha judge okay
there is this youtuber who goes by the
name
shoe on head she said to me michael i
think you're just
secretly in opposition to gay marriage
and adoption
but you're just using paternity leave as
a way to hide that and clearly this
woman has never listened to my show
because i don't think i've been exactly
shy about my opposition to redefining
marriage but this does pose a real
issue here because
there are the only argument i've ever
heard that's even somewhat compelling
for paternity leave is it's not so much
for the dads to take care of the kids to
sit at home for a couple months and
change diapers and chest feet or
whatever it's so that the dads can take
care of mom
while mom recovers from the physical
trauma of
pregnancy and of childbirth
obviously in pete budajej's case he
doesn't have to worry about that because
there's no mom at home
and so it does raise this issue of the
redefinition of marriage and the family
because there are two ways that pete
buddha judge could have acquired these
kids that he's now going to raise and
it's not clear he's been kind of cagey
on which one it is the first one is
adoption
and if these babies were adopted what
that means is that in a country where
there were 36 couples approximately
trying to adopt every one infant put up
for adoption
some adoption agency decided to deprive
these children of being raised by a
mother and a father and to choose to
have them raised by two men
and if you're fine with that
what you are saying is that there is
nothing that mothers add
to raising children there is nothing
that mothers uniquely or especially do
that fathers don't do there's no special
role for moms and for dads it's all just
the same
mom and dad are exactly the same they're
completely indistinguishable
and
i know that a lot of people pretend that
these days but i don't think very many
people actually believe that when you
think back to your childhood were mommy
and daddy exactly the same did they
fulfill exactly the same roles and
neither of them added something special
to your upbringing
bo they were just completely
interchangeable no no one really
believes that the other way that buddha
judge and his partner could have
acquired the kids is even more morally
dubious and that is through in vitro
fertilization and surrogacy
and this is a process whereby a man will
choose a woman out of a catalog purchase
her eggs and then use the womb of
another woman to implant an embryo and
then get rid of the women altogether and
just just raise the kids
and this is more morally dubious because
it involves the intentional creation of
a baby for the express purpose of
denying him his natural mother which is
wrong it's a wrong thing to do babies
have a right to their
mother i i don't want to seem like i'm
just beating up on bootage and his
partner here
i actually have a great deal of sympathy
for it i have even empathy for them okay
this is sort of a personal issue
in in the sense that when i got married
sweet little elise and i we are catholic
all right we started uh getting ready
for the baby machine right away
and it didn't happen right away and if
you've ever dealt with infertility
problems of any sort you know this is a
very
painful thing it's very difficult and
i'm sure that buddha judge and his
partner
just have a natural longing to have a
kid
but they don't
have the desire or the willingness to do
the things that naturally lead to a kid
and so
i remember when we were trying to have a
kid you know my wife said
well oh gosh maybe we should do ivf
maybe we should do this maybe we should
do that catholic church does not permit
that because they're morally suspect
processes whereby multiple embryos are
created some are just put in a freezer
forever some are destroyed and it's it
can be a really
bioethically wrong
process
and the conclusion that we came to is
that
yes it's good to have a kid that's a
good thing to want
but a good end does not justify immoral
means okay
it's good that buddha judge and his
partner want kids that doesn't justify
depriving that child of his natural
mother or of the opportunity to be
raised by a mother and a father okay so
that's the that's the part that a lot of
conservatives are probably not going to
say because they they don't want to seem
like they're being mean to bootage and
his partner but and no one wants to be
mean to them but it's just a fact and
one has to think about the broader moral
implications here and one has to think
about kids and one has to think about
what it means to have a father and a
mother and these sorts of realities the
third part that's ridiculous about this
story
and this is probably the least popular
opinion of all but it's true is
that paternity leave
is a very silly concept okay it is it's
a very modern silly concept and i'm sure
that there are many listeners out there
who took paternity leave or who plan to
take paternity leave i do not begrudge
you your employment benefit
it's perfectly natural to take advantage
of all the benefits you can
but it's a silly thing it's a very new
thing there used to be such a thing as
maternity well there used to be such a
thing as mothers staying home and
raising their kids
then as more and more women entered the
workforce in the 20th century there was
such a thing as maternity leave because
mothers have a lot to do with their kids
when the baby's born one
the mothers have to recover from
pregnancy and childbirth
two they have to breastfeed
three they have to nurture and bond and
take care of this little baby
fathers
don't really have to do that okay
they're actually it matt walsh got in
trouble for saying this over the weekend
there actually isn't all that much to do
for
dads for their little babies when
they're born we're not gonna chest feed
okay we're not i guess we can change
some diapers or something but it it's
it's a little bizarre i think for men to
stay home for two months or more in the
case of bootage edge
to
change diapers or something babies need
their mothers when they're born and they
need their fathers too but in a
different way they need their fathers to
go bring home the bacon show them a good
work ethic i think there are a lot of
conservatives who believe that
policies such as paternity leave are a
way to rebuild the family
to not just focus on the crazy
market-driven
economics-obsessed aspects of politics
but to focus on the family too i do not
think
policies like paternity leave help
rebuild the american family i think
policy is like paternity leave
actually
come from the same sort of gender
confusion that led to this problem in
the first place
because we're pretending that moms and
dads are exactly the same
they're not
they're really not i do think
that this is a political problem though
it's not a personal problem it's not
just a hey man suck it up and go back to
work and pick yourself up by your
bootstraps no that
the problem is that mothers do need help
right after their babies are born and in
in the old days
there were two ways they'd get that help
rich people would pay servants and less
rich people would have extended families
all around them right cousins and
sisters and all sorts of relatives who
could come help out and in our modern
economy
most people don't have the money to hire
someone to help them and they don't live
anywhere near their family because we
live in this world where we just we move
away from our families we don't have we
don't have very big families we don't
have extended families nearby so i agree
this is a political i don't think the
answer is just
hey you know let's get rid of paternity
leave and suck it up and figure it out
no we need to figure out a legitimate
genuine authentic way to rebuild the
american family
just one policy off the top of my head
in hungary hungary
will exempt you from paying income taxes
if you have more than four kids
or maybe it's four kids or more so if
you have four kids or more you just
don't pay income taxes it's the
government directly trying to deal with
this problem of declining birth rates
nations such as ours having less than
replacement levels of of fertility and
which is one of the reasons why a lot of
people encourage mass immigration is
because you need to have people to
bolster the economy that would be one
way to do it
but pretending
that daddy is exactly the same as mommy
and there's no difference whatsoever
that is not the way to rebuild the
american family
now speaking of health you've got to
focus on society's health you've also
got to focus on your own health which is
why i would recommend checking out super
beets a lot of people think that if
you're slowing down throughout the day
all you can do is just have more and
more caffeine just another cup of coffee
a tenth cup an eleventh cup of coffee
well i got a new way to start your day
to keep yourself feeling good that would
be super beets heart chews a tasty treat
that gives you the energy you need and a
treat that is good for you no more
afternoon coffees energy drinks and
candy for a quick pick-me-up add two
delicious plant-based super beets heart
chews to your morning routine promote
heart-healthy energy for your day
without a caffeine crash
the grape seed extract used in super
beets heart shoes has been clinically
shown to be two times as effective as
supporting normal blood pressure as a
healthy lifestyle alone a lot of people
over here at the daily wire have started
eating these super beets i got to hide
them so that people don't don't just
keep eating them because they're also
pretty tasty so they'll just like pop
them back like candies
i would strongly recommend that you
check out super beats heart shoes for
heart healthy energy
join over 1 million customers get free
shipping and returns a 90 day money back
guarantee and right now you get free 30
supply with your first purchase at
superbeats.com
knowles that's superbeats.com
knowles
pete buddha judge took a quick break
from his
months-long paternity leave to go on tv
he got caught in the scandal he goes on
jake tapper's show and he wanted to
gaslight the american people on
inflation and the supply chain well
certainly a lot of the challenges that
we've been experiencing this year will
continue into next year but there are
both short-term and long-term steps that
we can take to do something about it
look part of what's happening isn't just
the supply side it's the demand side
demand is off the charts retail sales
are through the roof and if you think
about those images of
ships for example waiting at anchor on
the west coast you know every one of
those ships
is full of record amounts of goods that
americans are buying because demand is
up because income is up because the
president has successfully guided this
economy out of the teeth of a terrifying
recession
this massive transportation crisis that
we're in right now it's actually
actually it's a good thing huh and
all of all of the consequences of that
and some of the causes you know like the
fact that you got to pay a lot more
money and you're not getting the goods
that you want that's actually that's
good
man if this is good
man what's bad
[Music]
it's so
it's so weak but you're seeing here the
beginning
of a white house line initially i
thought
this was pete just grasping at straws
trying to hold on to his job and saying
no inflation's good you know no supply
chain crises are good because people are
buying stuff
they're not really getting it but
they're buying it yeah it's really good
but it's not just pete who's making this
claim
the white house chief of staff just a
few days ago ron claim
came out he retweeted this comment he
said quote
most of the economic problems we're
facing inflation supply chain etc
are high class problems
we shouldn't have had them
or wouldn't have had them if the
unemployment rate was still 10
we would instead have had a much worse
problem so because the unemployment rate
was artificially high during covid
because the government mandated that
businesses shut down
joe biden's administration is now taking
credit
for
fixing the problem that was artificial
in the first place
right the government it's not as though
we just had an
actual unemployment crisis it's not as
though people you know the government
couldn't figure out ways to
incentivize companies to hire people
it's that the government went in and
said stop it shut down your business
shut down don't buy anything don't
produce anything stay home
so it created this artificial
unemployment crisis and then the
government started to say okay you can
kind of go back to work again see look
how great we are we fixed unemployment
well no that you didn't really you just
took your
you took your you know foot off the
brakes for a little bit and so the the
economy started back up again
but and now they're saying as a result
of this inflation's going up and the
supply chain's going up i think there
are the supply chain is having problems
first of all there are other causes of
this namely we just gave people a bunch
of money and printed up a bunch of money
for a long time so that
i suspect that has something to do with
the inflation
and the supply chain crises are caused
by this dumb economic policy that shut
the whole world down for for a year
but you can't whatever your views on the
cause of these things you can't say it's
just a high-class problem
if you are having trouble
meeting ends meet right now if you're
having trouble affording gas which is
going through the roof if you're having
trouble getting basic household goods
that's not just the
rockefellers who are dealing with that
that's everybody actually not only is
ron plains claim false
in fact it's the opposite of true
people
kind of forget about inflation but
inflation
far from just affecting the wealthy
disproportionately affects the poor
so for starters wealthier people are
more likely to offset inflation with
rising income okay they're more likely
to be able to deal with that just on the
income level but also prices tend to
increase more for basic goods than they
do for luxury goods
which is a phenomenon that's called
inflation inequality
so you're going to deal with higher
increases in prices
for
toilet paper for basic food staples for
gasoline than you are for your audi or
your bmw okay prices might go up for all
of them but they're going to increase
they're more likely to increase
disproportionately for the basic
household goods
so it's not a high class problem it's
actually more a low class problem okay
it's actually more
a
middle and working class problem than it
is
a wealthy problem and this is the
official white house so it's not just
buddha judge saying this at the
transportation department it's not just
ron clay and the chief of staff saying
this in an interview
it's the official white house spokesman
jenn saki
who went on jake tapper's show and said
rising prices actually
are good
doesn't it seem tone deaf to say that
rising prices and empty grocery store
shelves are high class problems isn't
that a bit dismissive well that's not
exactly what the tweet said nor the
retweet of the original tweet uh which
is what we're talking about here it is
true though jake and economists will
tell you this and i know you've
interviewed some of them as well that
the fact is the unemployment rate is
about half what it was a year ago so a
year ago people were in their homes 10
of people were unemployed gas prices
were low because nobody was driving
people weren't buying goods because they
didn't have jobs now more people have
jobs more people are buying goods that's
increasing the demand that's a good
thing at the same time we also know that
the supply is low because we're coming
out of the pandemic
and because a bunch of manufacturing
sectors across the world have shut down
because ports haven't been functioning
as they should be these are all things
we're working through
okay so that's their story and they're
sticking to it rising prices and supply
chain problems are good now there's a
problem and you got to give jake tapper
credit here he points out the problem
which is under trump when trump was
dealing with some inflation
ron klain the same guy now who's
claiming rising prices are good
attacked donald trump for those rising
prices and described it as a attack a
sort of tax on the middle class
so jake tapper asks jen saki
what changed then between then and now
why did ron claim think that rising
prices was a serious concern under trump
but not under biden i can tell you from
sitting in a lot of meetings with ron
clayne day in and day out he is obsessed
with lowering costs for the american
people and that's driven from the
president
hold on
you just told me jensake that rising
prices are good and they're the signs of
a healthy economy
but now you're telling me that ron claim
is doing everything he can to lower
prices
so or
makes me think that the rising prices
are bad
so are the rising prices good or bad
because you've just told me completely
contradictory statements within the span
of about 15 seconds
and it's because jake tapper calls out
the bs which he on occasion actually
succeeds at doing
and she backs off immediately she goes
with this bs white house line rising
prices are good then he goes actually
that doesn't make sense she goes look
we're doing our best okay we're trying
we're trying we're trying to lower the
prices please don't yell at us please
that was easy that was easy to knock
down that ridiculous
argument and the inflation is it's a big
deal right now
the inflation
has now risen 5.4
from a year ago
this is now matching a 13-year high
according to the associated press the
lesson of course is pretty simple
eventually the bill comes due
okay the bill comes due nothing is free
and this is obviously true in the
financial
sector but it's true generally it's true
of society it's true of culture
we live in a culture where
people seem to believe
that you can get something for nothing
or that you can radically upend certain
aspects of society and that will have no
consequence on the rest of society okay
and it kind of gets back to the
paternity leave thing right either
obviously the bill comes due for
paternity leave
literally it comes due the company has
to pay more money or the government has
to pay more money or whatever
but
the social bill comes due as well
you can't
radically redefine what it means to be a
husband and a wife what it means to be a
father and a mother what it means to be
married what it means to have a family
and then
expect that that won't
radically alter everything else in
society the family is the fundamental
building block right it's the it's the
basic political unit
and i think there are a lot of right
wingers who have believed mistakenly
over the past
decade or two
that it's no big deal yeah whatever
redefine everything and it's okay just
don't make me pay for it
you know redefine everything totally
upend our basic institutions but hey
don't infringe on my rights don't well
guess what pal i i think we're beginning
to see this
that will have an effect on you can't
you can't do that you can't you act it's
amazing that these kind of economics
obsessed conservatives don't realize
that there's no such thing as a free
lunch if you missed the sunday special
this weekend i highly recommend you
check it out ben is joined by none other
than barry weiss a terrific writer
journalist and now the voice of her own
podcast called honestly with barry weiss
go check it out at dailywire.com or on
ben's youtube channel
daily wire members get access to special
bonus content from sunday's special
episodes do not miss out join daily wire
today also subscribe and start listening
to the morning wire on apple spotify or
wherever you listen to your podcasts
leave a five star review if you like
what you hear
also by the way if you happen to be in
washington dc
come check me out tonight i'm going to
be flying out yet again right after this
show
head over to dc with my friend senator
ted cruz and we're going to be taking
verdict our verdict podcast on the road
we're going to catholic university you
can check that out tonight get all the
details at yaf.org
i hope to see you in dc or at least on
the live stream at the yaf and
verdict youtube channels we'll be right
back
joe biden is threatening the navy seals
as a general rule it's not smart to
threaten navy seals they tend to be
pretty tough hombres
but the biden
defense department
is threatening navy seals why is this
because
a number of seals don't want to get the
covey backs
number of people in the special forces
the number of people in the military
broadly
don't want to get the covet vacs
and
when you join the military you sign away
basically all of your rights and people
who join the military take lots and lots
of vaccines
but they take vaccines that have been
pretty well established against things
that pose a grave threat to them
kovid doesn't meet either of those
criteria
okay the covid stuff is a little bit
different because for the vast majority
of people covet doesn't pose
a particularly grave danger and the
coveted vaccine is brand new and there's
no we don't know anything about the
long-term effects because obviously not
because
it's only been around for what six
months or a year
so there just aren't any long-term data
and we have heard reports of blood
clotting that's why they pause the
johnson johnson vaccine and of
myocarditis and pericarditis the cdc and
the fda both acknowledge that end of
nerve damage and of
other issues too and there was a study
out of uc davis
just one one study but we all quote
studies these days that showed that
young men certain young men face greater
risk from the vaccine than from the
virus so these seals and these other
service members
say i don't think we really want to get
that
well the bind administration
is threatening to remove them from
special warfare
so you know they're special operators
they can remove that designation from
them or reduce their salaries or
force the seals to repay
the costs of their training
right the seals
receive some of the if not the best
military training in the entire world
ever
and it's not cheap it's expensive
training and so what biden's saying is
well if you're not going to get the vacs
you need to repay us for that training
now why is it i think people are kind of
missing the the heart of this story
they're focusing this uh focusing rather
on
the
lack of gratitude that the biden
administration has for their the
military or for the lack of respect the
biden administration has for the
military
i don't think that's the big issue i
think what the story shows actually is
the incompetence of government okay
because why the argument for making the
seals repay the costs of their training
is that once these guys get out of the
service what are they going to do
are they going to go
drive uber
probably not maybe probably not are they
going to go
work at starbucks maybe probably not
you know what i think they're going to
do i think they're going to go become
contractors
and do exactly the same job that they're
doing now and make about a bazillion
dollars more money it's much more
expensive
to pay the salaries of these contractors
than to pay the salaries of the enlisted
and the listed men and the officers
because the united states is still going
to need
special operators the united states is
still going to have this military need
especially if china keeps aggressing on
our interests
so what's going to happen is the biden
administration is going to say get the
vacs then a bunch of people are going to
leave they're going to say i don't want
to get the vex then those people are
going to go work for private contractors
and then the binding administration is
going to say uh oh man we need those
warriors back okay go get the
contractors go pay and pay them whatever
they want
and those contractors are just going to
be former seals
and another sort of special operators
and other people who quit
is they don't want to take the vaccine
there actually is a limit to what the
government can do here
they don't have infinite power and
infinite resources there are some basic
constraints
okay you're seeing this now
number of companies are beginning to go
back on
their vaccine mandates there was a game
of chicken that was being played between
the
corporations with the backing of the
federal government right the
corporations who were using the biden
administration's ridiculous vaccine
mandate as an excuse to force the vacs
and the workers
there's a game of chicken and it's led
to lots of cancelled flights and tsa
members walking out and
employees generally walking out and cops
walking off the job and they're they're
fighting fighting fighting and then in
many cases the corporations have caved
which we'll get to in just one second
worth pointing out though
the people in st
instilling these mandates and demanding
these mandates don't really believe this
stuff joe biden and his wife dr
jill biden
the the most acclaimed surgeon
dr
doctor doesn't have an md or phd but
she's a doctor you and and
and
vindman is a lieutenant colonel
and jill biden is a doctor and
damn you if you won't use their proper
titles
biden and jill got caught at a
restaurant in dc
not wearing the mask so they're walking
in the security detail they're wearing
the masks the staff members at the
restaurant
have the masks on and someone there was
filming this happen from their table the
restaurant and biden and his wife don't
have the masks on because no serious
person is worried about the masks
including i'm not saying joe biden's a
serious person but he's serious enough
to know that the masks are just not that
big a deal
and so he walks in and it's so flagrant
i thought when i watched this i thought
joe biden must know that people have
cell phones joe biden must know that
people film him wherever he goes
dc has a very strict indoor mask mandate
dc forces you when you get to a
restaurant you have to put the mask on
then you walk to your table and then
you're allowed to take the mask off
you're in the bubble of protection and
then at some restaurants this actually
happened to me last time i was in dc
you the waiter comes to the table they
say excuse me sir while we're at the
table you need to put your mask on while
you're ordering
they're that strict about it
and joe biden just doesn't wear it and
his wife doesn't wear it
doesn't he think he's going to get
caught
well the the sad answer is yeah he he
knows that someone's going to film him
he just doesn't care
there's one set of rules for you there's
another set of rules for him and what
are you gonna do about it what are you
gonna do about it punk
you can't do anything joe biden man he's
the most popular president ever in
history he got 80 bazillion votes oh
yeah he got more votes than anyone ever
and he's super popular
and oh you're protesting him and
everyone's chanting let's go brandon and
he's his poll numbers are tanking and
yes so what so what what are you going
to do about it
at the moment very little at the moment
very little
is it any wonder that people don't have
trust in these guys
in the bidens and the fouchies and all
of these
creeps who are taking away our rights
and our way of life and our traditions
and even our ability to dress ourselves
the way we want and forcing us to muzzle
ourselves
is it any wonder we don't like them very
much
well dr fauci has a different take
voucher says the reason people don't
like him very much
is not because of anything he's done
or any lies that he has told
or any contempt that he has for the
american people
it's because of conspiracy theories
why do you think
you've become so controversial and
honestly do you think there's anything
you have done that has contributed to
that well i'm not so sure i could answer
the latter because i can't think of
anything but i'm sure some people will
but you know chris i have stood for
always making science data and evidence
be what we guide ourselves by
and i think people who feel differently
who have conspiracy theories who deny
reality that's looking them straight in
the eye
those are people that don't particularly
care for me and that's understandable
because what i do when i try very hard
is to be guided by the truth and
sometimes the truth becomes inconvenient
for some people so they react against me
that just is what it is there's not much
i can do about that chris
i am the way and the truth in the life
okay and uh well hold on wait
uh
i i think there is someone who is the
way in the truth in their life and i
don't think it's you
dr fauci
he i'm not i don't think i'm
exaggerating when i say that he just
said he is the truth and he said that
often he says i am science and science
is me and i am the truth people react
against me because they don't like the
truth right it's kind of a weird
rewriting of scripture
he says he's the wave do what i'm doing
order your life in the way that i'm
telling you to and i am the life or
you'll die
if you don't do it i say you're gonna
die
talk about a god complex man and to
chris wallace's credit he says hey hey
fouch
do you think maybe you bear any
any at all responsibility for the
opinion people have of you
nope
uh uh
not even a little bit
no it's all them they're bad and stupid
i'm dr fauci
good grief man what a you know he's a
really good politician you can tell
because he never admits that he did
anything wrong ever do you think the
reason people don't like you dr fought
you might have something to do with the
fact that you lied to them at your very
first moment in the epidemic you said
masks don't work it's your opinion that
masks don't work and you shouldn't wear
them and then five seconds later you
said actually they do work and you
should wear them and then when asked to
explain it you said well yeah i lied to
them so that they wouldn't buy up all
the masks and then take them away from
the healthcare workers who i think
deserve the more
yeah but believe me now
you think it has anything to do with
that kind of stuff do you think it has
anything to do with 15 days to slow the
spread
that we're now entering our
595th day of just about
anything has anything to do with that
i think it has anything to do with your
not wearing a mask when you don't think
you're on camera with your cancelling
christmas with your
ceasing power and power more and more
and more power
with your
holding power in dc through seven
presidencies now yeah has anything to do
with that no no no
they persecute me because i am the truth
oh okay
must have missed that
some good news on this front though
i alluded to it just a moment ago
we're winning a little bit on this
battle with the corporations we're
playing a game of chicken
corporations are saying you got to get
the vax you got it you got to do it the
government's telling us you got to do it
and workers are saying no maybe not
and then the
the corporations on occasion back down
including delta
delta airlines
had a pretty strict vax mandate
i've flown delta a bunch
since the the lockdowns hit
and
delta i always found was the best
airline they had the best service most
meticulous sort of stuff
which ironically meant that during covet
it was the worst airline
because they were so meticulous because
they're so
focused on you know the details of their
job that when their job entailed the
making people wear the dumb mask they
were hyper focused on it and they
were hyper clean and they wouldn't let
you you know have a drink or any of
these sorts of things so
delta came out
and said we're gonna have a vax mandate
and the workers said please don't
and then delta just back down ed bastian
the ceo of delta
quote acknowledge that there will need
to be religious and medical
accommodations made for those who wish
to remain unvaccinated while avoiding
having to threaten employment status
this according to fox business quote by
the time we're done we'll be pretty
close to fully vaccinated as a company
without going through all the
divisiveness
of a mandate
that's a change of tune
because initially you heard we're gonna
yeah we're gonna mandate it baby you
gotta do it
put up or shut up or get out right and
you saw this with united united laid off
a lot of people who wouldn't get the
vacs
and joe biden bragged about it
he said yeah a ton of people lost their
jobs but look now united has a 99
vaccination rate yeah because they fired
all the people who wouldn't get it wow
that's one way to
solve employment problems
but what delta's saying is no
we're going to encourage people to do it
we're going to incentivize people to get
the vaccine
but we're not going to force them to and
we're not going to take their jobs away
if they don't
great stuff that's the way to do it
and i suspect they did it one delta is a
good company it's basically a well-run
company but two
the people pushed back okay and delta
looked at the power they had
and they said this is not the way
this is not a good way to run
a company
the people pushing back against
entrenched power is a very wonderful
thing when the people are abusing their
power
who are in those those positions of
authority you see this in loudoun county
the daily wire broke a story the other
day that finally the establishment media
have had to acknowledge
in loudoun county
there was a rape
that took place
in a bathroom
and it was a violent rape of a young
girl
and
it took place in a school where the boys
are allowed to go into the girls
bathrooms if they pretend that there's
no difference between men and women
there was a boy who occasionally wears a
dress
and he allegedly raped this girl
and the school covered it up
school covered up because obviously the
gender bending policies had some role
here and we all like to pretend that
there's no difference between men and
women and mom and dad and girls and boys
but there is there's a big difference
and the reality keeps reasserting itself
and so the school covered it up well the
superintendent of that school has just
acknowledged he wouldn't apologize be
acknowledged what he did scott ziegler
he said this lack of oversight that
existed prior to my tenure also
contributed to errors in our state
reporting regarding disciplinary
incidents in schools the division
inadvertently omitted some information
in the past this is extremely concerning
we're making
steps to make sure that this is improved
no nobody you lied is what happened you
lied
you i'm glad that you're you're not
admitting that you did anything wrong
but you're admitting some wrong was done
now you should either resign
or be investigated and then
resign or be investigated and resign and
possibly go to jail this is a good first
step and it's only because the people of
loudoun county were pushing and it's
only because of that great investigative
journalist at the daily wire keep
pushing keep pushing hold this
jerk this moral idiot to account
the ruling class is really really upset
that
parents are pushing back
against entrenched power especially at
the level of the school board they're
really really upset about it you
remember i referred to him earlier
lieutenant colonel vindeman alexander
vinman was this
twerp who
was undermining civilian authority and
was really anti-trump during the trump
administration
and he was testifying
uh before congress and someone said mr
vinman so and so and so
and he stopped that person and said how
dare you
i'm lieutenant colonel vindeman kind of
like when people correct
uh people for saying mrs jill biden
that's good doctor joel biden okay so
lieutenant colonel vinman said that
parents showing up to school board
meetings that's not how democracy is
supposed to work
literally a woman at the school or
meeting said
she wasn't able to sign up to talk about
critical race theories so she signed up
to talk about salaries and her first
opening salvo is i'm here to talk about
salaries you shouldn't be getting yours
because you're not doing your job
so
this is what they want to say like we're
only going to pay you if you do what we
tell you
you should do and that's just not how
things work in a democracy i'm sorry if
you were listening to that you might be
under the impression that lieutenant
colonel vinman had a sex change it was
it's not been who made the comment it
was vinman's wife who is an activist of
these sorts so uh clearly uh a lot of
resemblances here in the family and the
way that that the vinmans look at
democracy
lieutenant colonel vinman did not like
the idea that the people made this
choice to elect donald trump and
vinman's wife does not like this idea
that people are asserting power in their
local communities and going up to the
school board
this is not how democracy works that's
exactly how democracy works that's why
we have school boards
that's why
parents
show up to these meetings and voice
their opinions it's a reminder though
that when the libs talk about our
democracy and they pretend to care a lot
about our democracy they don't really
mean our democracy they mean
their oligarchy and they mean at a
philosophical
level liberalism
and democracy and liberalism are related
concepts but they're not the same thing
you could have a rather conservative
democracy you could have a rather
right-wing democracy
and it wouldn't be particularly
liberal right so if when the people for
instance go and elect donald trump that
is a great expression of our democracy
but it's not very liberal
and when the left uses this phrase our
democracy they're they're referring to
liberalism okay this is not how
liberalism is supposed to work
parents are so according to liberalism
and according to progressivism
the parents are supposed to be thrilled
the critical race theories being taught
in schools
the parents are supposed to be thrilled
that little johnny is being told he can
be little jane
that's supposed to be a wonderful thing
the fact that parents of all stripes of
all shapes of all different ages
are pushing back against this
that's a great rebuke of liberalism and
the vinmins can't
tolerate that
okay and they're gonna they're gonna
fight back the ruling class is gonna
fight back and the ruling class still
has a lot of power
a new york city judge
has just barred a father from visiting
his three-year-old daughter
unless he takes the fouchy algae
or submits to weekly covid tests
because
the judge says judge matthew cooper
says that
it's not in the child's best interests
this according to the new york post
the father was unnamed here obviously
the parents are divorced or getting
divorced and the judge says no it's not
so three-year-olds face statistically
an
infinitesimally small risk
from coronavirus
but
if this dad won't go along and get the
experimental drug to fight against the
cough that poses a relatively very low
risk even to him
he won't be able to see his kid so yeah
look we're not going to mandate the
vaccine
we're just going to take away your job
and your money and your ability to go
out and your ability to interact in
society and your kids
if you don't do it
so you want to do it you're gonna get it
are you gonna do it come on just do it
this is
techno medical
tyranny
that's what it is and this is this is
why i would strongly recommend
that if if you are asked
about whether or not you've had the
vaccine
don't tell people
i i've seen this on both sides okay i've
seen some people who are they're the
kinds of republicans who
like love
the idea of this vaccine and they were
really afraid of the coronavirus and
they say look i love the vaccine i'm
three pro vaccine this is the ground
this is the greatest vaccine ever but i
don't think it should be mandated but i
love it i got it i got i got seven of
them you know i'm about to get one next
tuesday
but i don't think other people should be
forced to get it
then on the other side you've got some
conservatives who are really proud of
not having the vaccine and they'll say
they'll they'll brag about that they'll
say oh yeah i didn't get the vaccine i'm
not going to get the vaccine there's
there's no way i'm ever going to get the
vaccine i would not recommend
saying either of those things
because
we're living in a world where this is
real where this is a real form of power
and where real entrenched authorities
are using vaccination status to lord
power over other people and so for your
own self-preservation and for the good
of society writ large
i would basically just not disclose
whether or not you've got whether you
think the vaccine is dumb or whether you
think the vaccine is great i would
probably not disclose
because the way that the authorities are
wielding power here
is by
is through knowledge it's through
knowledge of who is vaccinated the
reason that biden pushed for that osha
vaccine mandate when he did
is because by that time
at least according to the data the
majority of americans had received some
sort of vaccination
he couldn't have done it at the
beginning because not enough people had
done it and so they they already knew
that they were outnumbered at that at
that point
now they know that they've got the
numbers so they can probably push
forward so i would just i would deprive
them
of that sort of knowledge okay these are
people with a very radical agenda and
they want to upend a whole lot of things
not just the economy not just the supply
chain not just inflation not just look
joe biden himself said it or his
representative said it that they want to
use this opportunity of the lockdowns
and the epidemic they want to exploit it
to rework the entire economy
they want to rework the way that dads
can see their kids they want to rework
the way that every political institution
is structured down to the family they're
going to rework everything up to and
including
paternity leave don't
let them
don't make it easier for them to
completely reorder your society i'm
michael knowles it's the michael knowles
show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021 on
the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show